this video was made possible by better
help.com / Pakman where you can get
affordable online access to a licensed
therapist through text phone and video
chat
just click the link under this video
let's now talk about a very specific
case not of fall sexual assault
allegations but of real sexual assault
allegations I wasn't actually going to
cover this I wasn't going to cover Bill
Cosby's sentencing on the Regular Show
but some of the reaction to his
sentencing has been so absurdly out of
order that I do want to talk about it to
catch you up Bill Cosby was a beloved
television actor from The Cosby Show of
decades ago in American culture Cosby
and The Cosby Show were super important
it was the first representation of sort
of a everyday upper-middle class black
family Cosby played doctor cliff
Huxtable and then Cosby as an individual
became known for speaking out about the
tribulations of the black community and
specifically of black men and not
everybody agreed with Cosby but he was
undoubtedly an important figure within
that movement but as all this was going
on we now know Cosby was a truly
depraved predator of women he drugged
women in advance of sex all sorts of
different scenarios
dozens of accusers in total he is a
dangerous sexual predator and between
expired statutes of limitation and all
sorts of other circumstances he evaded
criminal justice for decades but finally
his drugging and sexual assault of
Andrea constant 14 years ago caught up
with him it took two trials but he was
found guilty and yesterday Judge Steven
O'Neal sentenced Cosby to three to ten
years in state prison
he is 81 years old now this may be
effectively a life sentence for Cosby we
don't know but immediately all sorts of
nonsense started being said about the
sentencing and in general about the
prosecution of Cosby people saying for
example Cosby looks so sad in his
picture his mugshot I guess we would
call it as he was being taken into
custody I feel so bad for the guy and
then the truly bad argument started
being made one such argument was that
this is racially
motivated I saw a meme floating around
saying look Cosby was the only guy
convicted he's black but white guy Trump
hasn't been convicted and white guy Matt
Lauer hasn't been convicted and white
guys Bill O'Reilly and Harvey Weinstein
and Charlie Sheen haven't been convicted
this is very dumb
first of all Harvey Weinstein might be
convicted right that those legal
proceedings are only starting Bill
O'Reilly and Matt Lauer they may not
have done anything criminal right they
sexually harassed women and had
inappropriate relationships in the
context of their workplace it's not
clear that they actually committed crime
so I don't even really know why that
analogy is necessarily being made here
during the entire discussion of the me2
movement we've talked about how there is
a range yes all of these accusations and
what Harvey Weinstein did wasn't exactly
the same or wasn't at all the same as
what maybe Miley O'Reilly or any of
these other guys did and there are
levels to all of these things but what
Bill Cosby did was the worst out of all
of these accusations he drugged and
raped countless women and I actually
think that focusing on the racial
element kind of misses the power and
wealth element which is that Cosby
evaded justice until he was 81 in part
because he's part of the super wealthy
upper class which has a different
justice system right Cosby's net worth
of buy one report four hundred million
dollars is part of why he wasn't
convicted for so long and they finally
were able to get him and hold him
accountable so saying these other guys
who were white didn't get convicted in
this story is just not the right
analysis and then there's oh come on
he's 81 years old do you really need to
put him in prison the guy avoided
justice for decades and he was able to
live almost all of his life as a free
man for a very long time but he ruined
the lives of other people when they were
in their 20s when they were in their 30s
so it is a terrible argument to say he's
81 and so we shouldn't punish him the
fact that others are found more quickly
or that others are younger or that Cosby
was able to use his wealth to circumvent
punishment that has no bearing on the
fact that this guy did horrible things
and he is now being punished for them
full-stop right I mean if he was a
rested at the age of 40 and then spent
40 years in prison for what he did maybe
now you could look at his advanced age
and failing health and say we can let
him out under house arrest and all these
conditions but he got away with this
during the entirety of his life and you
know it's the only time that he can face
punishment and I hate to break it to you
but three years which is the low end of
that range with good behavior he may do
very little time like this may not
actually be a life sentence for Bill
Cosby anyway a lot of really just bad
ideas and arguments coming after his
sentencing